les autorités religieuses viennent de
reconnaître un 66e irak la lourde après
onze ans dans quête l'église confirme la
guérison inexpliquée d'un malade atteint
d'une sclérose en plaques malades qui
avaient fait le voyage à lourdes en 87
témoignage de cet homme recueillis par
françois privat et alain darrigrand à
angoulême on l'appelle le miraculé c'est
au cours d'un pèlerinage à lourdes en
octobre 87 que jean-pierre bélie 51 ans
à l'époque a été guéri d'une sclérose en
plaques
une petite chaleur qui a commencé à se
faire sentir au niveau de mes orteils et
puis qui a grandi commencé à monter au
niveau de mes chevilles de mes jambes
et puis qui a envahi tous encore alors
je dis moi si une chaleur qui me visiter
qui redonnait vie à tous les membres de
mon corps à toutes les cellules de mon
corps et je sentais cette sensibilité
cette mobilité qui revenait ya un moment
donné cette chaleur est devenu tellement
intense je me suis retrouvé assis sur le
bord de mon lit les jambes pendantes
puis en train de tâter les poignées +16
7 pour toute douce cette mobilité de mes
doigts qui était revenu les poignets
tout est où tous signes de la maladie
avait disparu
j'ai l'impression de rêver jean-pierre
choisit alors de rester discret sur ce
premier événement mais la nuit suivante
il a du mal à s'endormir et nous sommes
10 et lève toi et marche et mais avec
tellement délicatesse tellement de
tendresse et de respect de ma liberté
que j'aille plus quoi faire quand je me
tournais je me retournais dans mon lit
j'avais de nuit qui maquille entendez ce
manège est venu vers moi il m'a dit vous
vous voulez vous avez besoin de quelque
chose j oui il faut que je me lève et
j'ai commencé à faire mes premiers pas
mais comme un enfant qui apprend à
marcher ça m'a fait cet effet là comme
un bébé qui qui fait ses premiers pas la
même chose toujours considéré comme
invalide à 100%
cet ancien infirmier 66e miraculé de
lourdes souhaite protéger sa vie privée
moi j'utilise pas le mode miraculé moi
je dis tout ce que j'ai reçu c'est un
signe ça veut dire la même chose
mir accessing signe de la tendresse une
miséricorde de dieu moi je le vis comme
ça dans ma foi séance photo avec icônes
de bernadette soubirous ici on ne parle
pas de miracle mais d'un événement qui
sera officiellement annoncée ce soir par
l'évêque d'angoulême au cours d'une
messe exceptionnelle
le prix